just what is Special Counsel Bob Muller
investigating and why our next guest
argues the media are getting it all
wrong when it comes to the Russia probe
joining us now from New York with more
is former federal prosecutor Andy
McCarthy Andy I love your columns period
but I loved you're so good but I loved
your most recent one where you raised
the question of whether Muller has even
proven or even has a sense a clear sense
that Russia hacked into our systems
prior to the election explain well Laura
I want to be clear I'm not questioning
the finding of the intelligence
community I would stipulate that Russia
had a cyber espionage operation against
the 2016 election but what we all need
to focus on is the fact that that is an
intelligence judgment it's a probability
in fact their report even says the fact
that we render a judgment doesn't mean
that we could prove it as a matter of
fact and the problem that we have with
Muller's investigation is it's a
prosecutorial exercise which means you
have to prove every essential element of
the scheme of the crime beyond a
reasonable doubt to the satisfaction
unanimously of 12 jurors so even if it's
okay for the intelligence community for
the sake of protecting the country to
assume that Russia has these operations
against our country doesn't relieve
Muller of the need to prove it beyond a
reasonable doubt I don't think he can
the intelligence report itself says that
it would compromise methods and sources
of intelligence so they don't want to
make those available and we know that
the FBI never even physically took
custody of and did an examination its
own examination of the Democratic
National Committee service which are the
key evidence in the in the case can you
also you also point out in your piece
that they based the the real jump on
their investigation when rod Rosenstein
the Deputy Attorney General when he
he'll basically panicked and called for
a special counsel that's my view he was
like freaking out that the Democrat
on Capitol Hill were asking questions
instead of answering them he panics and
appoints Muller but mother's facing the
his investigation with Rosa Steen on
this on the contacts with Russia which
during a campaign as you point out
that's not a big deal it made almost
campaigns have some contacts with Russia
it's the second question which is the
operative one yeah the the Clinton
campaign and people in it had plenty of
contacts with Russia right the the thing
that would make contacts problematic or
incriminating is if they indicated
complicity in an actual espionage scheme
but you never even get there until you
can prove the espionage in the first
place and I just don't think he can Andy
let's go to Peter struck Jenni re Andrew
Weissman questions raised about other
people within the FBI lately about their
ability to be truly objective in looking
at this investigation to my eye we have
a lot of individuals who are you know
they're not just they're not just
Democrats they are Trump adversaries
both in their previous associations and
in their you know texts or tweets or
commentary during debates and so forth
you sort of have the jury's out for you
on Peter struck why well because as I
understand it and as Comey testified to
the to a closed session according to The
Wall Street Journal as then FBI director
Comey testified to a closed session of
the House Intelligence Committee in
March the reason they hadn't brought any
case against Flynn at that point was
because the agents who interviewed him
believed him and that was struck so you
know the fact that that Flynn ended up
pleading guilty to lying in that
interview was not stocks idea evidently
struck wasn't pushing that that was the
very aggressive Muller investigators
toward the end so I just want to see all
the facts on him come in Laura but I
think your your general point about
Muller's poor judgment in larding this
ridiculously inflated seventeen lawyer
team with Democratic donors and
activists is not only a big problem for
the integrity of the investigation I
were ultimately going to find that the
real collusion story of the 2016
election was the way that the Obama
administration put the law enforcement
and intelligence arms of the
administration in the service of the
Clinton campaign and a lot of these
Muller lawyers come from the top levels
of the Obama Justice Department yeah
we're running divisions or previously
representing Ben Rhodes when he was
testifying or being interviewed by the
House Intel committee representing the
Clinton Foundation as Jenny read it I
mean this is like a Venn diagram that
that is scary for me personally and it's
great to have you on